My sister's in town to visit and she's been craving bubblegum so bad,
but she ran out so I just decided to make it for her.
I poured some powdered sugar on some wax paper and created a well
before combining my gum base with some corn syrup
and slowly melting it down.
That was all melted.
I gave it a good stir
and poured it into my little powdered sugar wells I created.
One of her favourite flavours is green apple,
so I made a green apple one
and then also experimented with making a cinnamon vanilla gum.
Once the mixture was cold enough to handle,
I kneaded it and then stretched it out
and made sure to always have it covered in the powdered sugar
so it wouldn't stick.
Then I rolled out my gum,
cut it into equal pieces and decided to go for a little gumball.
Once all the green apple ones were formed,
I moved on to my cinnamon vanilla ones
and set them aside before tossing them in some more powdered sugar
to keep them fresh.
I placed them in some wax paper,
twisted the sides
and repeated that process with all of them
and then they were ready to try.
These tasted even better than store bought gum and she was so excited.
The cinnamon vanilla ones tasted like a donut.
I was very pleased about